[Music]
the grounds of this mistrust are that
the knowing consciousness is caught up
in the antithesis of the certainty of
itself
and objective essence ethical rightness
which holds that what actually is is in
itself nothing when opposed to absolute
law
learns that it's knowing is one-sided
it's law only a law of its own character
and that it has seized on only one of
the powers of the substance
the action itself is this inversion of
the known into its opposite into being
is the changing round of the rightness
based on character and knowing into the
rightness of the very opposite with
which the former is bound up in the
essential nature of the substance
converts it into the furies
who embody the other power and character
aroused into hostility this nether right
sits with with zeus on the throne and
enjoys equal honor with the god who is
revealed and known
paragraph
738 begins by referencing the grounds of
this mistrust in german just miss towin
a cognate and what we're looking at
there is the mistrust displayed
towards the situation as such and what
rule he ought to be following on the
part of shakespeare's hamlet now
hamlet is a little bit unusual as as
hegel just pointed out in the previous
paragraph among
tragedies in that instead of acting
the person you could say dithers
although he's not just a dilettante he's
trying to determine
what he should do how he should act and
whether
the
full weight of right
or law in this case is actually on his
side whether he's doing the ethical
thing and hamlet doesn't act the way
that oedipus does or antigone does or
so many other characters do because uh
he's not sure he has a sort of mistrust
now
this is not the case for
a lot of tragic
characters right
they may have some doubt but it's not
quite the same thing as the doubt that
hamlet has and they they do act and that
is what hegel
is telling us about
in this paragraph and we're going to see
an unfolding of the ethical substance
something that has been
neglected
overlooked is going to begin to come to
light
so he says the knowing consciousness the
knowing consciousness is also the acting
consciousness
is caught up in this antithesis
of two things the certainty of itself
and objective essence okay so the
viscende bovus and the knowing
consciousness in the case of hamlet this
antithesis is there for it it can it can
grasp this in the case of acting tragic
characters we're going to see that this
is going to be
at least for the moment put aside
and the way that the
antithesis is going to be handled
is the objective essence gets pushed
over here into what actually is
so certainty of self we've seen this
discussed a number of times throughout
the phenomenology there's really not
much more that needs to be said about
that
antithesis here gegenzotz opposition
works just as well in fact it's
translated as opposition
in just a little bit later by by miller
the same term
and so we don't have like an absolute
contradiction of wiedersbrook at the
center of being or anything like that
but what we have is a opposition a
contradiction between this certainty of
self which is rooted as we see a little
bit later in character
and objective essence so what is
objective essence here vasen is essence
vasin can also be being and objective
gegenstenli right there as an object
something that that is there and can be
figured can be understood can be
grasped now what this leads to
is as hegel goes on
ethical rightness
which holds that what actually is is in
itself nothing when opposed to absolute
law
okay what is the ethical rightness it's
there embodied in the
character the
actions the intentions the thinking of
that character ethical rightness
da si
liken right the z leakin that which is
ethical that which is rooted in the
mores that which you know we've been
trying to achieve the good
uh the right the
law the right
rightness
and it it opposes itself to what
actually is the virtually
what has
actuality or reality and it says
you know and this is kind of a common
thing that we see that is really
nothing in comparison it's not nothing
factually it's not it's not nothing in
terms of not having actuality but it's
nothing in terms of rightness
when opposed to
absolute law and this is im gagen zots
right in opposition to absolute law so
the absolute law reveals that what
actually is the current conditions
that seem to be
you know either of necessity or
contingency well they they don't matter
they don't embody
the ethical and the ethical has a
priority over them and should impose
itself upon them right and this is what
a character does through their action
their handling their comportment
they
you know do things oedipus
kills this guy who's in his way
arrives in town marries the queen makes
a bunch of kids decides he's going to
punish the killer of the previous king
brings teresius in compels him even
though teresa says you're not going to
like the answer to this right
so we can go on and on with examples
and he says that it learns its knowing
is one-sided
now that's important eins i take a
one-sided that's always a bad thing in
hegel's vocabulary right
because it means that something is being
left out of the situation is it truly
knowledge
if your knowledge is one-sided if you're
leaving out something
critical something central something
important and the answer is no i mean it
reveals itself
as not really
knowledge or knowledge only of a part of
it
he goes on and says it's law
only a law of its own character
so the ethical
the absolute law the ethical rightness
that it's imposing
is
indeed only part of the ethical
rightness he said well is it is it
ethically right then
well this is where we get to some really
interesting as hegel's going to say
reversals or
you know an um cairo and literally like
flipping everything upside down an
inversion a fair carrying right is also
you know karen is is a turning um and so
what actually is is going to attain a
certain value that it was being deprived
of and the ethical rightness is going to
lose the absoluteness that it was
investing itself with
he goes on and says
it is seized on only one of the powers
of the substance
all three of these phrases
go together
right
it has
now revealed its one-sidedness it has
only grasped one part of the substance
and it realizes that its law is a law
only of its own character
so
there is a
revealing that takes place here and the
revealing typically in tragedy is going
to take place on the part of the
character who now is struck with horror
or
fear
or
anger or you know disgust or pick
whatever other range of negative emotion
you want to talk about rather modality
right of negative emotion
uh regret
uh
remorse those are often among those as
well
and we're witnessing this this thing
happening but it also comes through
somebody else saying hey man you're
screwing up you left something out
you forgot about this didn't you right
and sometimes it happens through um
something being imposed on you you know
for example in macbeth
which is one that that shakes that
shakespeare wrote and hegel just
mentioned in the previous paragraph by
talking about the witches
macbeth loses right and a new regime is
established
after
he uh is is taken off the scene um in
the case of oedipus it's a bit more
complicated right the kids go on and
have
some screwed up you know relations with
each other and crayon is there in the
background as well
going on
he says that
the action itself the handling is in
this invert is this inversion of the
known into its opposite
into being is the changing round of the
rightness based on character knowing
into the rightness of the very opposite
with which the former is bound up in the
essential nature of the substance the
the rightness of the opposite the ant
gagan gazetteston again another term
that's that's kind of connected with
antithesis or opposition gaganza you
notice that we've we've got some similar
vocabulary going on there
in this case
what we what we are dealing with what's
been repressed what's been left out the
other side
of the one-sided
is the irenaeus the furies the
creatures that impose a different kind
of
divine rightness a kind of divine law
and he goes on and says that
it converts it into these who embody the
other power and character aroused into
hostility they have character as well
they have power mocked
and he talks about this as a nether an
an untera right underneath
right wrecked which sits with zeus on
the throne and enjoys equal honor with
the god who is revealed and known the
furies or the iranians the irenaeus
means the peaceful ones it's a euphemism
they're not actually peaceful they tear
things apart
they are the punishers they are the
enforcers of divine law and you hope
that you never run into them or see them
or hear them right
a great example of this is found in the
orestea where they actually are a
character
agamemnon is killed by his wife
clytemnestra and her lover who is
agamemnon's cousin against this orestes
is posed with a conundrum
do i avenge my father because that means
killing my mother or do i not kill my
mother because that's something that
you're not supposed to do but she killed
my father
he does kill against this and his mother
clyde manestra and then he is pursued by
the furies and you can say well why he
did the right thing
yes but it was only partly right
and this is the tragic situation as
hegel well knows and he thinks that this
is something integral to the development
of what goes on in a tragedy
to these three beings the world of the
gods of the chorus is restricted by the
acting individuality
one of them is the substance the power
presiding over the hearth and the spirit
of family piety as well as the universal
power of state and government
since this distinction belongs to the
substance as such when it is pictorially
represented it is not individualized in
two distinct figures but has in
actuality the two persons of its
characters
on the other hand the distinction
between knowing and not knowing falls
within each of the self-consciousnesses
and only in abstraction in the element
of universality is it divided into two
individual shapes
for the self of the hero has an
existence only as a whole consciousness
and is therefore essentially the whole
of the distinction belonging to the form
but its substance is determinate and
only one side of the distinguished
content belongs to him
therefore the two sides of consciousness
which have in actuality no separate
individuality peculiar to each receive
when pictorially represented each its
own particular
shape the one that of the revelatory god
the other that of the furies who keep
themselves concealed
in part both enjoy equal honor but again
the shape assumed by the substance zeus
is the necessity of the relation of the
two to each other
the substance is the relation that the
knowing is for itself but it has its
truth in what is simple
that the distinction
through and in which actual
consciousness exists has its basis in
that inner being which destroys it
that the clear conscious assurance of
certainty has its confirmation in
forgetfulness
paragraph 739
has the potential to be quite confusing
for the reader because of its initial
line and then what's going on in the
paragraph so what is this initial line
the way that miller translates it it's
to these three beings the world of the
gods of the chorus is restricted by the
acting individuality so we've got a
couple different moving parts so to
speak in that
we have acting individuality right and
that's just pretty straightforward it's
handled on individuality right so
handling acting engaging in some sort of
intentional
uh motivated course of action and then
confines
restricts what the god world the go-to
of the chorus and it's kind of weird
that he's talking about the chorus here
but let's go along with that for a
moment
two three beings
and other ways of translating this the
vasen right would be essences and some
other translators do in fact at this
point speak in terms of three essences
that doesn't really help you that much
whether we linger on that term or not
but what's going on here is hegel saying
look there's there's three
main things that are happening there's
another thing that's really important
that's going on in this paragraph
he's making a distinction
and not making it all that clearly
between how things
are
as they're more fully grasped and then
how things are
as again as miller's translating as
they're being pictured as they're being
represented for gestalt or in
foreshtelling right
so this this is quite important and now
why is this confusing well because hegel
then goes on and says
you know one of these and that must be
one of these beings is the substance and
then he says on the other hand the
distinction between knowing and not
knowing and in each of these we wind up
with two different
beings sides essences to them and you
can so if you're following it along you
might say wait a second by the time that
we get to the on the other hand and we
get self-consciousness it looks like we
got four different things so is this
like aristotle and the nick of mccain
ethics when aristotle starts telling us
that particular justice has two distinct
forms and then he enumerates a couple
more particular justice forms and you
know wait a second what's going on here
no
it it is actually
clear enough and it's it's once you see
what's going on it's not clear in the
way that it's written it's not clear in
the way that it's translated
but if you parse it apart you can you
can figure it out there's also another
problem as well
the you know a b and c at the end
doesn't neatly coincide with the three
beings
that we're dealing with here so this is
liable to produce a lot of confusions
and
let's start by distinguishing what these
three beings are before we look at the
passage itself so vasen number one
whether it's a being or an essence
is substance
and we're gonna come back to that in a
moment
being number two phase in number two
self-consciousness right now this
self-consciousness is a little bit more
complicated
as we just saw in the previous paragraph
um its knowledge can be one-sided
there's something that's hidden as well
and that is the furies or the uterine
a's
we'll get to that in a moment then vason
number three
essence
um
you know being being
the being of the god world
is zeus
why zeus well zeus is the king of the
gods zeus is
the top dog you could say
um
you know there's there's questions in
greek mythology just how powerful just
how universal is zeus but we're not
going to worry about that here and zeus
is just representative of something in
this and it gets very metaphysical and
psychological so you know you don't have
to call it zeus you could call it a
unifying principle if you want it or
whatever you like
so let's go back and look at at this now
so these three beings right one of them
is the substance and then here's where
hegel says there's actually two sides to
it he's not super clear about this but
it but you know thinking back to
the spirit section where this was early
on in the spirit section we have the
power of the family
and the nether gods and then we have the
power of the state
right the government and these can be
distinguished into two different things
the shot and the people who are engaging
in ruling but we're not going to worry
too much about that here the point is
there's this disjunction between them
and they're both part of the substance
what substance the ethical substance
right so he says that
you've got the power presiding over the
hearth what's the hearth the family
fireplace where you do the cooking where
you do
the heating things up where you might do
a whole bunch of other things as well
and the spirit of family
piety the connection between the
generations
the tutelary or familial spirits that
you have that are your families and not
the family down the street right and
then we have something much more
universal the universal power of state
and government might just be a city
might just be your village but it's
something that goes beyond the household
so this is this is one of the
the vasens one of the essences one of
the beings
we're going to come back to this in a
moment this sense this distinction bit
let's talk about the next one on the
other hand
the distinction between knowing and not
knowing falls within each of the
self-consciousnesses
and only an abstraction in the element
of universality is divided into two
individual shapes so we've got we've got
a sort of
bifurcated
self-consciousness between knowing and
not knowing what's the knowing part the
as he calls it the self of the hero the
character oedipus or antigone or
um
[Music]
hamlet himself or
pick whoever you want right
could be
agamemnon himself in the agamemnon could
be
um his son you know orestes in in later
plays we can go on and on with this but
what's the other side the the side of
not knowing the furies that which is
concealed and this is where it gets
really interesting so i mentioned the
word you know psychological
as well as metaphysical earlier
hegel seems to be saying here
that the
furies these divine powers of vengeance
or justice that the
one-sided vision of the character left
out
is actually part of the character it's
something that's repressed it's
something that comes along
it's something that's there
and has been
missed or overlooked
so
he goes on and says
the two sides of consciousness which
have an actuality no separate
individuality peculiar to each receive
here's where it gets really important
when pictorially
represented so when they're there in
foreshadowing as they are
in drama as they are in
other types of forshelling you know
paintings
vases
mosaics
epic pick whatever you want whatever art
form if it's representing them
these things can be split apart even
though they're not really
split apart they are
portions
of self-consciousness
arrestees in the play is pursued and
tortured by the furies
but it's really orestes himself
torturing
himself in you know if we understood
this not in a representative or
pictorial way but in a big league a
conceptual way hegel doesn't come right
out and say that here but that's the
only possible way to read this right
so now coming back to the other one we
see that this happens as well he says
since this distinction belongs to the
substance as such when it is pictorially
represented it is not individualized in
two distinct figures but has in
actuality two persons of its characters
one person representing the household
one person
representing the state
but really they are not that separate as
well and are these things
separated from each other
not totally
the third vasen as he says the third
essence
is um zeus he says in part both enjoy
equal honor but again the shape assumed
by the substance zeus is the necessity
of the relation of the two
to each other so that's a third
being the necessity of the relation
between
these
and zeus you know acts as a a character
or there's a stand-in for zeus in some
way right teresius you could say in a
certain respect uh in in the oedipus uh
rex right so we've got our three
substances here and then hegel brings
this to a close as i mentioned by
bringing in another triad
which doesn't map exactly onto this he
says that
the substance is the relation a
there's a miller interjecting this that
the knowing is for itself but has its
truth and what is simple
so there's our starting point right b
that the distinction through and in
which actual consciousness exists has
its basis in that inner being which
destroys it so the the in this case the
furies or whatever else is acting in
that way and then c
uh that the clear conscious assurance of
certainty has its confirmation
and forgetfulness for guessing height
right
and so we've got this interesting
dialectic of
things being brought to the fore things
being forgotten or concealed and all of
these are part of the picture of what
hegel is calling the
god world now notice i'm going to close
on this
is this all that there is to the the god
world of the chorus and the chorus
remember are those poor schmucks who are
there watching what's going on in the
play while we other schmucks sit back in
the audience and watch the chorus
watching this thing happening and we're
you know we're supposed to feel some of
the responses emotional responses that
are going on on the part of the chorus
or on the part of the characters right
acting individuality is the character we
should also keep in mind too that there
is a playwright
the playwright himself
is also engaged in handel
but a shafenden or a kunsalikaran uh
you know handle a productive a creative
uh action and so
it is the acting individuality within
the play that is confining these to this
dynamic but it's also the artistry of
the playwright
so
that's probably enough hopefully this
helps you
figure out where these different
references that hegel is
rather unclearly making fit in so the
paragraph is not as murky or confusing
as
it starts out being
you